okay year 12. i'm mindful of time
that's right i'm just mindful of time so
what i'm going to do is uh try my best
to unpack this
for you quite literally okay now the
important thing
we're gonna have and i don't apologize
for it because it's actually quite
elegant once you get there but
we are gonna have some quantity of
algebra soup on the board but i promise
i'll do everything i can to make it
clear
the important thing is the logic you use
to get to that algebra
algebra soup and then how you weighed
your way through it how you navigate
your way through it
so here's the most important question
and i actually heard it as some people
were discussing with each other how did
you do this
the first critical decision you must
make and i asked it with our previous
example
is here's the k plus 1 case you got a
left hand side
you got a right hand side which one
makes it easier
to use the inductive hypothesis now
this is one of the reasons why this is i
i wondered at first like what they put
this into extension too
sigma notation all that kind of thing it
used to be just in the regular old
advanced course what we used to call two
units like what's the big deal
and then i did this example for myself
and realized okay
left hand side right hand side usually
we would think the right hand side is
the easiest thing
to pull out the inductive hypothesis
from just like we saw in the previous
example
usually this means oh you've got all the
ones from the assumption
and then one extra one right this is
that's literally what we did last time
can anyone tell me why in this
particular question
you run into a big fat problem any
takers
it just seems weird to do famous
statement in many mathematical papers
uh anger's right and your instincts
sometimes even when you can't quite
articulate
them often and worth trusting but let's
see if we can do more than just
trust the engagement things right he's
exactly right that the binomial
coefficient is the problem have a look
at this guy with me
okay if we were to say consider right
hand side and maybe that's exactly how
your working has begun
right you then write this you write this
and then the first thing you begin to do
is
see how you can expand it to get this
part here
but you're in trouble immediately
because there's no twisting and turning
or let me say that again
you'd have to do a lot of twisting and
turning to turn this
into this uh just go back to that um
factorial notation that i said you
wouldn't have to use
to try and see the difference between
these okay the first one
is k factorial on r factorial
k minus r factorial there's the
particular binomial coefficient
in the assumption is that okay let's
have a look at it for the other one
hmm uh k plus 1 factorial
on r factorial
uh k plus 1 minus r factorial did i do
it right
i put k plus 1s everywhere i put k's and
you can do some stuff to this like for
example
this same unwrapping of sigma notation
you can do with factorials
this this top this numerator here is k
plus 1
k factorial do you agree and then on the
denominator you can do a similar thing
here this is one more than this
so it's like this times an extra term
all right i think you're gonna get this
k plus one minus
uh k minus r factorial take a breath
okay
but even as you look at that i hope your
brain is like please don't make me
please don't make me do that for any
more than one term it's a disaster
okay we don't want to do that there's a
better way
instead of doing the right hand side
let's have a look at the left okay
mercifully this is much easier right
here's the left hand side
and actually now that you look at it it
hardly takes anything
to reshape this so you can see the
inductive
hypothesis what's the difference between
this
and what you see in the assumption
yeah it's just one multiple of x plus a
difference between this and this do you
agree that's what the plus one
in the index means so as a result i'm
going to write this slightly weirdly
i'm going to use some colors here to
help me i said i was going to try and
make this algebra suit clear
i'm going to write the x in blue and i'm
going to write the a whoops
what am i doing even as he says he's
going to write it in a different color
he writes it in the same color i'm going
to write it red okay
now here we go okay
what comes next is the left hand side of
the assumption which is really good for
me because it means i can just use the
assumption
and that's exactly what i'm going to do
on the next line okay so i've got my
x and my a here man how does that
black pen red pen guy do it okay so
there's my
first binomial okay now i'm gonna
substitute here on the right hand side
uh this by assumption okay so let's go
ahead
and do it now i'm gonna save myself a
step i'm gonna have to expand this
anyway
sorry here comes a big bracket
what is this thing well i'm going to
start with first term
r equals zero right so what's my first
binomial coefficient going to be
i'll give you a clue it starts with a k
k kc zero right
yep next one long's going to be x to the
power of
k minus zero so i'll just write k and
then a to the power of zero
which is just one so i'll just leave
that okay next term along
kc1 and then what happens
one less k sorry one less x and one more
a
is that all right so one less of these
and one more of those i need to
establish a pattern so i'm going to get
to the third one
one more oh sorry one less x and
one more a and then dot dot dot what
will my final term be
um have a look closely right i'm going
all the way up to
k aren't i so it's going to be k
c k all of the x's by this point see how
they start i started with a lot and then
they're climbing down down down down by
this last term i have
no more of them so i'm not even going to
write x i'm just going to write a
and then i've got all of the a's there
okay now why did i highlight these two
colors
up here right you're not gonna like this
but i'm gonna expand why am i gonna do
this okay
remember i'm trying to turn n's or in
this case
k's where have i got to get to i gotta
get to these guys
right do you see where i'm trying to get
to i've got all these
wrong coefficients in there and i've got
to find
these guys turning into this guy
does that make sense there's going to be
pairs of them they're going to turn into
the binomial coefficients on the next
line okay so
here's what i'm going to do i'm going to
write this and i'm not going to do it
uh on one line you'll see why in a
second
what's the first term going to be kc 0
and then what
i'm distributing this x to everything in
there what am i going gonna get
x to the power of k plus one because i
started with k of them and now i've got
one more
let's do the next one uh k c one
how many x's have i got this time
k of them it's this times x so okay and
then there's an a
hanging out there i'll do one more just
to get the pattern okay c two
one less x one more a
and then i say dot dot where do i end up
k c k and then i just multiply it by an
x
there we go is that okay one so hard all
right
now i need to do a multiplied by
everything
but i'm going to do it slightly off i'm
doing it on the next line
and i'm going to push it over one term
so that there's some cancelling that
happens not quite cancelling collecting
if i multiply a by this first term in
here
i'm going to write it here i get k c 0
should be a plus sign there
and then how many x's are there x to the
power of k
like nothing's changed to x i've just
multiplied by a so it's x to the k
and then there's an a because that's
what i was doing right multiplying
everything by a
even before i go any further do you see
this is this is happy times for me like
you see i've got
like terms that are going to collect in
a second let's do the next one
ah okay see uh
one what am i gonna have
x to the k minus one i haven't changed
it at all
and then it's it's actually sorry it's
this one here isn't it
wait did i get that right it came out no
i was right sorry i'm looking the wrong
way it's this one here it is a squared
going crazy okay is that all right you
can see it still
is gonna connect here plus dot
dot now i need the second last term
there's actually a term
before this one that would be uh
x a to the k minus one and when i
multiply that by a
what's going to happen you're going to
get k
k minus 1 it's going to line up with
this
and then i have the very very last term
which like the very first term doesn't
match or doesn't pair with anything
so it's going to be k c k
a to the k plus one and you can see this
kind of nice symmetry here
you've got this one with a k plus one oh
a k
plus one it's almost like i wanted a k
plus one you've also got this one
with a k plus one so things are starting
to look like what i wanted
okay all right so we kind of just ran
out of time
at the end of the lesson there so what i
want to do is pick up where we lift
left off uh try and tie this up in a
nice neat bow and then
also uh because we have now the luxury
of time
uh prove this result upon which this
induction actually relies
which i kind of gave you i reminded at
the beginning of the lesson about
pascal's identity
but i just kind of referred to it and
said yeah it works let's use it but we
didn't actually go through a proof in
the context
of this particular question so let's see
if we can close this all off
and then deal with pascal's identity the
last thing
we did was we took this uh somewhat
messy object
this x plus a out the front from the
original binomial expansion
and then the actual expansion of what we
got from the sigma notation
which was part of our inductive
hypothesis our assumptions so
we kind of got to write down what the
expansion was at least
part of it and you can see what i've
done here is that color coding between
blue
and red this line here is what happens
when i multiply
everything inside these square brackets
by x and then what i've got down in here
in red
is what happens when i multiply
everything in the square brackets by
a now the thing i want to remind you of
and i'm going to use some highlighting
here that will hopefully
be instructive and helpful is that
there's going to be
collection of like terms there's going
to be several terms
in the blue series that match up with
terms in the red series so which ones
are they
now if i just have a look in the first
instance let's use um
let's use orange yeah you can see
there's this x to the k
times a term here and its binomial
coefficient
k c1 and then it matches in the red
series with this x to the k a
term which has a different binomial
coefficient k c
0. so that's orange i'm just going to
keep on going along identifying as many
as i possibly can
here is the x to the k minus 1 a squared
term
in the red and then the corresponding
term
in the blue and then in terms of what
i've actually written here the final
terms that i've got pairing up matching
up
let's go with i think i can use pink
over here
here is our x a to the k term in the red
series
and the x end of the k term is the last
term
in the blue series now it's also worth
highlighting
everything in between is going to match
up even though
i haven't got the term that corresponds
to this in the series above it will
match up and the same with this blue
term over here
there are two terms that will not match
up and those are the very
first and last terms the first term in
the blue series
that's this one here there is no
corresponding x to the k
plus 1 term neither is there if you look
at the end
neither is there a corresponding a to
the k
plus 1 term so they're going to be left
on the edges
and separate so let's start to pair
these things up
in the first instance i'm just going to
write x to the
k plus 1 because of course k c 0
any integer c 0 is going to give you
just
one so i'm not writing it at the front
there that'll become important later on
then i go to let's see if we can keep
this color coding consistent i'm going
to write this orange because it's
highlighted in orange up here
the next thing that turns up is the x to
the k a
term but what is the coefficient out the
front of it well there's the two
binomial coefficients that go together
so let's just write that carefully
you've got the k c
1 term and the k c 0 term
that's how many x to the k a's there are
let's go to green to do the next one
it's going to be let's see here k
c 2 plus k c
1 that's how many of the next term i
have
k minus 1 a squared and then
we get this dot dot happening
the intervening terms in the other dot
dots they're also going to match up up
here
and then i pick up with this pink term
let's see get the right color here
there we are and this is the x to the a
k terms so
in brackets what have i got actually you
know what i'm just going to go on to the
next line
i'm going to have k c k
and then k c k minus
1 that's how many x to the a k's that i
have
and then the very last term again this k
c
k by definition and also you can use the
factorial notation to see
that that's just going to be one as well
just like the opposite term
you can also think about the rows of
particles triangle the first number
on any row and the last number or in any
row are going to be one so
i'm not going to write that one since
it's multiplica multiplying it doesn't
change anything
it just leaves me with a to the k plus
one
all right now this is fabulous because i
can now use
this pascal's identity business here
right you can see
looking at one row of pascal's triangle
if you take
two adjacent numbers that n stands for
the row and then
this r and this r minus one stand for
two numbers on that row that are beside
each other
then what they're equal to when you add
them is the next row down
and the corresponding number so when i
take this to
these terms down here i can take these
dual binomial coefficients in the kth
row
and combine them add them up into a
single binomial coefficient
on the k plus one row now while i'm at
that
i'm also going to include the fact that
um these
first and last terms this one and this
one even though i simplified out the
k c 0 as 1 and the k c k as one
i'm trying to get things like remember
this is all um the goal is here i'm
trying to get things in terms of
uh the k plus 1 case so i'm going to
have k plus 1 c
r out the front i can write this in
terms of a binomial coefficient with k
plus 1 in it it's just going to be i'm
seeing daisy doing that a lot today
the k plus 1 rho and it's the zeroth
coefficient just like it was the zeroth
coefficient for this row so
that's how many x to the k plus ones
i've got
all right let's go back to orange so
what am i going to have
here well i'm going to add i'm going on
to the next row
k plus 1 and then it's going to be the
first term which is a relief because you
can see here's the zeroth term here's
the first one it's just the next one
along so that's going to be my x to the
k
a term what am i in green now i've got
the k
plus 1 row and i'm up to the second term
x to the k minus 1. so you can see at
this point i have well and truly
established my pattern but let's finish
it off
what do i get here i've got the pink
term so that's going to be
let's have a look so k plus 1 rho again
it's going to be the kth
term so that's x a to the k
and then finally i'm also going to add
in
that this k c k i can replace with k
plus 1
c k plus 1. so now you can see
everything
is in terms of this correct binomial
coefficient okay now when you have a
look at this line
it's uh it's brilliant because when you
have a look at each one of the terms
they are at last in the same format
you've got the binomial coefficient
on the k plus one throw you've got next
term which starts at k plus one
and it goes down to k and k minus one
and when you arrive at the end you have
no more x's left
then you've got these a terms which
start it there are no a terms here zero
terms
there's one of them there's two you go
all the way up to k plus
one so what is this i can be extremely
lazy and i can say
this is exactly what i was looking for
here
on the right hand side of my k plus one
case so i can say that equals ta-da
that in sigma notation which is what i
was aiming to prove
so uh you do have to be fairly careful
with your segmentation and also with
your binomial coefficients
but i think it's just brilliant that we
can prove this very very important
combinatorial result
using proof by mathematical induction